-I want to ask,
as well, about this,
´cause this is
mind-blowing to me.
Obviously,
this was a crazy year.
Donald Trump...is president,
but also...
-Nice one.
-...he was on the show.
But you have
a connection with him.
This is a true story.
-This is a very true story.
-I would not believe this
if there wasn´t --
-He is my father.
-Yeah.
I have, right here --
I have a paternity test
that I´m about
to show the audience.
-It´s an ultrasound,
a little orange ultrasound.
-You went to jury duty.
-I got called in for jury duty.
I had postponed it
a couple times,
and this was the last time,
so I had to go.
-And he was there.
-He was there.
When I showed up, there was
all these things there.
I´m like, "Am I about to go on,
like, a murder trial?
What´s happening?"
And this happened.
-And there he is. Look at him.
I mean, that´s definitely him.
-I took a little creeper photo.
-Yeah.
-And that´s him.
He specifically asked to sit
between those two ladies.
Got his picture taken.
-Yeah.
Got his picture taken
and then got up and left.
-Oh, he didn´t stay?
-Oh, no.
He was there for maybe
a half an hour,
as long as it took to
take the pictures...
-Got it.
-...make a couple weird jokes.
-So, like, make it --
´Cause I was gonna say, like,
the fact that
he went to jury duty is --
If he had actually gone
and done the whole thing,
I´d be like, "I don´t care if
he [bleep] pays his taxes."
Like, that´s more impressive
to me than that.
But you´re just saying it
was Photo Op City.
-I believe it was
the week he announced
that he was running
for president.
It was like a couple days later,
so I think he felt
he had to be there.
-Yeah, he basically said
to the judge --
It´s like, "Is there any reason
you can´t serve on the jury?"
He´s like,
"I´m gonna be president."
-"I´m gonna be president.
It´s gonna be great."
God, I never --
I should have done Trump.
What was I thinking?
I should have done
Trump on "SNL"
-This is very exciting.
Your show, "Me, Myself & I" --
This is a very interesting
premise for a show.
You, John Larroquette,
and a younger actor
all play the same character at
different points in their lives.
-Yeah, Jack Dylan Grazer.
He´s in "It" right now.
Plays me at 14.
It´s three different timelines.
You see me at 14, in 1991,
at 40 years old, in 2017,
and at 65 years old, in 2042,
played by John Larroquette.
-And have you enjoyed
the difference in schedule of,
all of a sudden, doing a sitcom
versus the "SNL" grind?
-Very much so.
My first day at
"Me, Myself & I,"
I was in every single scene,
and it was like a 12-hour day.
And they were like,
"We are so sorry.
We apologize."
I was like, "This is like
a half day for me.
I was like, "This is the
easiest schedule in the world."
I was like,
"No, it´s the best," yeah.
-You also had one of
the highlights of your life?
You got to work
with some people.
You´re very --
I don´t even know.
Is "people" the right term?
Probably not.
-I keep saying it was
the best weekend of my life,
and then I remembered
I had a daughter.
-Yeah. Like, not that far ago.
-But it really
was the best weekend.
-You did The Muppets
at Hollywood Bowl
and you got to work with
The Muppets.
-I got to host "The Muppet Show"
live at the Hollywood Bowl.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How -- Was it outstanding?
-It was, man.
Those guys are
so insanely talented,
and it´s so hard to do that
and do everything,
but to do it onstage at
the Hollywood Bowl and, like --
It was truly amazing.
It was the best.
I got to sing
"Rainbow Connection"
with Kermit and Paul Williams.
-Oh, that´s fantastic.
-Oh, he´s the best.
-If you´re gonna sing it with
anyone, those are the guys.
-Correct, correct. Yeah.
I miss them.
-Well, congratulations.
Congratulations on everything.
Thanks so much for being here.
Fatherhood, the show.
-Yeah.
-Always good to see you, Bobby.
-Thank you so much, man.
-Bobby Moynihan, everybody.